But,
uh,
one of the things they're doing in Panama.
I sat my mom down there to a doctor Neil Riordan cause very good.
Yeah.
Do you know who he is?
I had him on a show with,
uh,
with Mel Gibson and Mel Gibson's dad was 92 when he went down there.
He's in a wheelchair.
It was all fucked up eight years and he walked back a hundred years old.
He's fine.
He's a hundreds,
108 years old.
That's what happens when you 92 and you live eight more years.
Thanks for doing the mass.
That's what happened to him.
He yells shit out and you can,
you can say racist shit.
You get it off your chest.
You lift to you a hundred.
Well,
it's only the booze that makes them racist.
I know.
Fucking guy's my hero.
Fucking love Mel Gibson.
He's as he ever made a bad movie.
Um,
I mean,
made it himself.
Maybe becoming a few shit,
shit movies,
but to know toxic masculinity right there.
I liked Apocalypto or that.
I thought that was great.
A lot of people shit on that.
It was right up your alley.
Yeah.
I loved it.
Yeah,
exactly.
I'm fascinated with that.
I wish,
wish I was apart.
No,
I love that movie.
I,
you know,
I think he's a,
he's a very intense,
very unusual,
eccentric guy.
Like just being around him,
you,
you get this sense of his energy.
It's like,
well,
it's all over the place.
All right.
Like rigged them out.
Yeah.
From lethal.
I don't have that.
Like a lot of that I think probably came like that,
that character probably came from like the dark inner workings of Mel Gibson's
mind you had really is,
you would like yell like that too,
though.
I.